hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from round four of the 2020
progress masters well-practiced festival
the Masters Edition it's ali reza future
versus nikita Wittig of and what
happened in this game is just it's just
a shame and what I mean by this is well
you will have to wait and see now so
without further ado let's check it out
and we'll hopefully get there as quickly
as possible so again we have a very nice
rule opus it's the same line if you lose
you're played in round three against
Hari Krishna but V to go over it takes a
bit of a different approach after a
certain set of moves so let's see for
now we have e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
sorry about that
we have Bishop to b5 the reuleaux pieces
on the board and a6 more fees defense
Bishop a4 Knight to f6
we have castles and Bishop to e7 we have
D 3 so the the closed rule opus we have
b5 pushing the bishop back Bishop to b3
and d6 now so all all standard stuff we
have c3 making room for the bishop on C
- after the Knight attacks it and now
black just castles we have h3 and here
it's the same position if it was already
had against Haida Krishna in round 3 and
we're how the creation of when tonight's
the a5 but here we have h6 by V - both
still waiting with with well his
intentions with the night and this
position has been reached a few times
the rook to e1 is a known move there's a
Bishop to e3 is a no move here nice to H
to maneuver fall by f4 is a known move
here but fuchsia again goes for a for
the same breaker on the Queen side he
did against Haida Krishna in round 3 so
what's what's happening now it's a new
move so of course as of move 10 we have
a completely new game now which ago
continues with Bishop to b7 simply
continue in development and rook to e1
now making room on f1 for the night the
days the usual plan night is coming to
d2 to F 1 and then 2 e 3 or g3 depending
on what black plays rook to e8 preparing
Bishop to f8 and now Knight B to d2 for
the future
with his plan Bishop to f8 and now
tonight's the f1 so again both players
are going with with the usual ideas and
only now Knight to a5 the show back to
c2 by Fallujah and now c5 so grabbing
control of the d4 square and now Knight
e3 with ideas of maybe coming to d5 or
f5 in the future of course depending on
what black plays we have Queen to d7
developing the Queen connecting Brookes
and now Knight to h2 making room for the
for the f4 pawn of course a V to go is
not interesting waiting for that to
happen so we have D for a sorry d5 now
that that it is possible first eight
characters on b-58 captures on b5 and
Queen to f3 and now you have to decide
what to do d4 seems like a reasonable
idea where you pretty much lock a lock
out both of these bishops out of the
game but after night 5 it's it's really
an excellent square for the knight and
it's not gonna be easy to kick it away
from there you can't play g6 because
both the knight and the bishop are on to
that h6 pawn and the well a lot of
attacking potential or opens up here for
white so instead after the screen to f3
move we have c4 by fatigue of now going
for this captures and then 4 captures so
Ali Reza has to do something about this
so he goes for Knight h2g for now
threatens just Knight captures and f6
which would ruin black's pawn structure
so Knight captures Knight captures and
now D captures on e4 which again makes
sense you have the capture with the
point which again locks your
LightSquared Bishop out of the game and
the Queen to East 6 just defending the
e5 pawn as the knight was attacking it
we have Queen to g3 now with threats of
Knight captures on h6 with checks since
the G pawn is pinned at the bishop also
helps out with this so you will not be
able to capture with the Queen so King
to h8 going back and only now f4 white
wants to open up the center hopefully
play e5 at some point which will free
his light square bishop but this will
also free blacks light square bishop so
you have to see is it actually worth it
so here he captures an f4 with bishop
characters on f4 and now Knight to b3
are trying to trade off some pieces both
the knight and the rook or attacking
white rook on a1 so look back to d1 not
back to d1 that sometimes I say back to
d1 even though this group was never
actually on d1 but rook to d1 grabbing
hold of the open D file and now rook a
to d8 we do both counters the rook now
with E 5 as planned which opens up the
light square bishop like I said also
opens up blacks light square bishop so
it's interesting to see what happens
here we have Knight to c5 my video book
it's the strongest move you have ideas
like first eliminate one of the rooks
then maybe bring the knight over to e4
where you will maybe have maybe force
White's to give up his light square
bishop for your lights per Bishop as you
will be harassing the Queen it will be
an excellent square for the knight and
so on so here after Lucia finds an
excellent idea
rook captures an d8 rook captures an da
and now Knight to f6 and this is the the
star move of the game although not
really but we're gonna get to that here
at the moment if you lose I played this
he had like maybe 12 and I have 13
minutes on a clock clock and the vehicle
had about 25 minutes on the clock but he
really started to burn his time and I
think he he also got down to about 10
minutes after he decided what to play
here
so one thing you should consider when
someone places something like this is to
just capture it if it's possible you
should do it now but first we have to
check what about Queen to b6 if if this
is possible it should win because we
still have point is that maybe maybe we
don't want to capture here and allow
captures and this opens up an attack
with with the rook towards our queen
but if we go Queen b6 we're still
threatening to pick up the night but
we're also threatening 94 with a
discovered check and the night we'll be
going after the Queen so if this works
this should be excellent however white
white can go Bishop captures an h6 here
and after this night Stewie for Czech
opening up also an attack towards the
Queen now you bring back the Bishop
Bishop e3 and you attack blacks Queen
and now you could go for Knight captures
Bishop characters on b6 and rook to be
to going for this g2 pawn but white has
this safety move Bishop to e4 tonight
characters Knight captures and here you
can capture on b2 the material is equal
but black has the bishop pair and insane
pressure along this diagonal that's a
that's a very weak weak pawn so it's
hard to say black will definitely be
better here so you have to decide what
to do here so the Queen to b6 definitely
an option for me to go
however he calculates properly and he
goes G captures on f6 now what happens
here even feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out how to continue
here over the white well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on continuing the attack properly and
for those who who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen to h4 problem is if you
do this right away and open up an attack
towards the Queen
you cannot capture with the Queen of
course that's that's a big no because of
the ship to e5
you just blender your queen so you have
to go for Knight to e4 now block the
attack and also attack White's Queen
after the ship characters you'll get
Bishop captures and now you're down a
piece it's hard to continue the attack
you really don't have much for example
if Queen e3 you go after Bishop Bishop
d5 and black keeps the piece if Queen
back to g3 Queen to c6 and again you
don't have ways of continuing to your
attack Queen h4 going after the pawn
here King to h7 you defend it and you're
just up a piece and winning with black
so after G captures on f6 you cannot
recapture right away if you reach a
played Queen to h4 now putting pressure
on the h6 pawn and now comes roof to d3
trying to give back some material to
numb down White's attack because this is
a very strong leadership however there
is King to g8 King to g8 gets out of any
harm's way but here white always has the
option of just drawing the game on the
spot
Queen g3 checking back Queen h4 King
here and we could have a draw by
repetition so vehicle decided to fight
he played rook to d3
blocking futures bishop
here and what do you do now well of
course Bishop captures on h6 it's the
strongest move you are threatening
Bishop characters on a faith with the
discovered check the Bishop captures on
h6
and now not a right away to recapture
because King just moves and you don't
have a way of continuing but first you
go for this he captures on f6 now you
have the thread of Queen to h6 check
followed by Queen to g7 mate and here
there is only one good move for video
gov and it is the move he plays he has
the part with his queen so Queen
captures on a1
incredible stuff Queen captures anyone
and now Knight to e4 now the rook is no
longer the rook is no longer pin now the
route can move but then again you you
will lose the night so you have to
decide what to do here
Queen to h4 for white of course going
after the bishop with king to h7 and now
you could go for captures captures but
the bishop already guards d2 so you
don't really want to allow black to
start pushing this right away and it's
not like you can move the knight just
captures and captures so it's not really
a problem so first Queen to h5 here
future goes after the f7 pawn and now
comes Knight to d6 defending the pawn
and here g4 really going all out the
thread is g5 which will just win the
game on the spot so what what to do here
here the ship to f3 was played Viterbo
finds an interesting way how to prevent
g5 because of course Bishop captures on
age 5 and now this is the real magic
moment of the game this is where the
magic happens or or maybe not we will
see what happens
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this immortal too strong move while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the immortal
took Swan move the title of the video is
maybe a bit of a hint but not too much
it's still not an easy move to find what
you have to realize in this position
that black cannot move any of his pieces
so basically you win this position by
wasting a move either with Bishop to be
won this is very strong
the shop to be won this is a good move
King to f1 also a good move so basically
you waste a move you go Bishop here and
what happens now
well black has to play something you
cannot move the rook because well it's
on the same diagonal as the King you
cannot move this point you cannot play
you can but after captures you're pretty
much in the same position only down upon
you cannot move the knight because of
Queen captures on f7 you cannot move the
bishop because it's pinned you cannot
move the King because you lose the
bishop so what can you move you can move
the bishop although we cannot move the
bishop just anywhere for example if you
move the but you can't go here you can
go here if you go here to e4 then just
captures on d3 and after captures g5
just wins the game you can't you don't
want to play you far right away because
rook to g3 check is an option here
so after Bishop to be one you have to
waste a move Bishop to e2 is an option
or Bishop to be one it doesn't really
matter what black plays because if you
go to e2 then the king will just kick it
back to d1 Bishop back to d1 and the now
came to f1 again waste a move because
black teas are the moves you have to
play with the bishop once again Bishop
back to f3 only Square and now King you
want and now you no longer have a move
you can't if we go anywhere here just g5
is an option if you go here or here you
use the bishop the King will just gobble
it up so you have to go here but now
it's the same idea captures captures and
the g5 of course wins the game right
away you don't have anything here just
captures and and this will be made so
that it's completely reasonable
so after Bishop to f3 this or this
really incredible stuff but as they were
both a really long time here it's move
35 and they both still have to really
have to reach time control they were
down to a minute and a half or or a
minute something and they had they have
to play really quickly so if you Lucia
played Queen to e5 here and well it's
also the white still has it has a good
position now this Bishop can move and
that's well of course a big help for me
to go he goes Bishop back to f8 now
defends the night as of course the
threat was just to capture the rock and
then pick up the night and here King to
f2 again if you go for this capture for
example characters characters in Queen
III Bishop to e4 depends it defends the
pawn and it's still a very complicated
position yes you can play h4 and
continue pushing and white will probably
eventually win this but with so little
time on the clock it's not easy to
decide on this a future played King to
f2 now again threatening to win some
material but now with you go counters
Knights the e4 width check King to f1
and now King to g8 not allowing the
Queen to come over to the H file with
check so we have Queen captures and b5
now grabbing the pawn but now comes Luke
the d5 and now this is a very active
rook so what happens here and what can
you play here that's the question of
course if Queen cappers and c4 just
Knights the D to check pics of the Queen
that's out of the question
so Queen to be eight by future but now
comes Luke the b2 putting pressure on
the bishop forcing now Bishop to capture
on e4 Bishop captures with Bishop
captures and here h4 now if you just
starts pushing his pawns but Bishop to
d3 with check King G 1 we have Bishop
back to e4 King back to f1 Bishop to d3
check King g1 and it was in this
position and move 45 that fusion which
you have agreed to a draw because it
actually is a draw if you continue this
it will only take black a few moves to
consolidate if you if you give if you
give him a few moves and then well the
Queen against the bishop pair and the
rook of course will not be an easy game
for example if the game continues lie
said Bishop before and now you continue
pushing let's say g5 now you already
have ideas like Ruchi - checking f1 Rudy
- and it's hot still hard to find a way
for white to push if h5 then you can go
rook to d5 you go after the pawns and
let's say you do make a breakthrough
characters and h6
it looks promising but again Bishop d3
chocolates a king you want and rook d7
and here you will not be able to make a
breakthrough if if Queen here let's say
you go after robust up there 5 and there
everything is defended this is nicely
defended this is nicely defended the
rook prevents the pawns from being
pushed so that's not a problem and now
black will slowly but surely start
improving his position and well it can
also go wrong for white so after King to
g1 really a one of the one of the good
draws that I've seen lately and it's
it's really a shame that it didn't work
but you know with the so little time on
the clock finding finding this move
waster this Bishop to b1 or King to f1
definitely not not an easy decision sir
unfortunately for future he didn't get
complete his immortal hooks one game but
he definitely created it it was just a
matter of executing it but you know that
that tends to happen in chess but always
always interesting game so we both
Volusia and we to go so we'll see what
happens next in the tournament that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Randy raveling guy
Lokesh marquel and Connor Egan and
Walter abrasion v out for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Prague
chess masters continuing the Morphy saga
and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Saturday